bonne nouvelle cette semaine la petite
vie va reprendre du service vous allez
remettre le costume de Rénald pour 6
épisodes c'est pas fait pour ces
épisodes 6 de milliers
ça reste un avalicieux rénal de Paris
mais il vieillit comme tous les
personnages et surtout préoccupé par sa
santé qui veut il veut vivre il est
avericus sur le nombre d'années qui veut
qui doit capitaliser pour essayer de
vivre le plus longtemps possible en
forme pour être un amant combatif et un
moment combatif
je pense une
une fougue sexuelle ou préserver une
fois que sexuelle parce que souvent ces
gens-là qui vivent dans un univers très
contrôlée comme ça que l'argent les
finances c'est c'est apparemment c'est
de faire toi que c'est des amants
combattifs
cette année-là
que ce futur rocher Richard Martino
comment ça se passe le service à la
clientèle avec les gens que vous avez
imité puis vous croisez dans la rue la
plupart du temps c'est bien le mot qu'on
entend pas le mot qu'on n'ose pas dire
c'est Google
les femmes le prennent beaucoup mieux
généralement que les gars les gars sont
plus
sont plus ils sont plus coques c'est
comme plus mais les femmes sont plus oh
ils sont plus bonnes joueuses en général
que les gars pour le reste bah oui il y
en a que ça je sens bien que ça blesse
malheureusement les grands crus
tremblaient ça s'en est une après cinq
belles années et les Québec avec
l'émission c'est cette année-là vous
débarquez à nouveau avec un nouveau talk
show mois d'avril c'est courageux c'est
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix-là de
quitter votre maison en fond à ma grande
surprise que je réalise c'est que quand
je faisais le grand blond c'est pas un
truc traditionnel comme le grand blanc
pouvait qui était pas si traditionnel
non plus mais avec des invités qui
s'enchaînent moi j'ai laissé ce show là
avec il se passait des choses dans ma
vie personnelle qui était qui était
difficile et qui qui ont pris toute mon
énergie puis mon attention à ce
moment-là puis j'ai dû terminer
pas dans un état où tu dis ah j'ai
terminé quelque chose et je le savoure
jusqu'à la fin fait qu'il me reste un
manifestement chose que je croyais pas
mais il y a comme un champignon dans de
Last of Us qui se développer en moi puis
qui a monté dans mon cerveau puis que je
fais a là on me donne l'occasion de de
contaminer j'aimerais contaminer encore
j'ai été vraiment émue par le texte
publié en novembre dernier sur pour le
projet solo Radio-Canada vous racontez
votre voyage en Inde 21 22 ans vous
vouliez abandonner le métier de comédien
pour faire autre chose j'ai lu ce
texte-là comme un grand cri d'amour pour
Fabien oui c'était ça j'allais beaucoup
trop loin pour chercher quelque chose
qui était c'est ça dans le fond puis la
femme qui est devenue la mère de mes
enfants avec qui j'ai passé 23 ans de ma
vie qui a eu la patience la générosité
de ma tante pour faire ses enfants là
même si on savait pas à ce moment-là
qu'on ferait ça mais il y a une marque
d'amour là qui
qui m'a donné beaucoup de force pour
me définir par la suite
[Musique]
j'additionne les élans de coeur et
générosité de cette femme là mon égard
puis aux égards à l'égard des enfants
c'est incroyable j'ai été bien chanceux
terminons par une autre bonne nouvelle
au mois d'août 2023 on pourra voir
Toupie et Binou le film
vous avez des enfants ouais ouais
version française
[Musique]
qui ont la gentillesse peut-être de
faire semblant d'être
dose d'enthousiasme puis à ceux qui font
c'est pas vrai
de cette horreur là qui stresse qui me
donne mal à la tête qui qui m'agresse
que mes enfants après avoir été une
épisode par trois fois plus fort que ce
qui parle à l'ordinaire
là c'est comme ok mais je me suis rendu
compte que
[Musique]
un peu un peu je pense que toupie à
l'âge adulte
après une carrière de toupie va devenir
croustique j'ai l'impression peut-être
que to be va rester un éternel enfant
mais j'ai l'impression des fois que
suffit enfin il suffirait pas de grand
chose pour amener à toupie dans dans le
chemin de la gaine des enfers
sur ces sages paroles donc la brèche
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS bravo pour
pour cette belle carrière
prochaine fois on va le faire